you mentioned before that when you were
terminally ill
you felt like well i've lived a good
life
so it's not that bad if i die it's okay
in many respects
but then you looked at the suffering of
your family and thought okay this
matters at least it matters to them
yes no you mentioned that in a positive
light but when i was thinking
there's plenty of people and i count
myself as a part of this group where i
used to be where i
used to be depressed and in fact i was
suicidal and
it's not it's harrowing to think that
to know that the main reason you're
staying around is
to lessen the suffering of others rather
than your own internal locus
of a desire to live but you mentioned it
in a positive light so
can you expound sure so
um i did think when i was diagnosed that
i had lived for
uh my my aunts died my aunts and uncles
died young and so i thought oh i guess
i'm one of them
that then i'm going to die young like
them and
and and i can
i can do that i'd always been a very
independent person
making my own decisions and getting on
with life and this was just another
decision that i was making that's how it
felt to me
that this was another decision that i
was making and that i was
tough and i could do it so that was my
plan and then i went home from the
hospital and i went to tell my children
and when i told them the prognosis they
looked so hurt that something inside me
completely changed and i realized oh no
i'm not looking at this properly
this is not this isn't my decision
because i always wondered about people
who had gone through
many cancer treatments you know many
times going through chemotherapy and
radiation
and the the things that people go
through to stay alive
why would they do that you know i've
always kind of wondered why
they would do that and i had thought no
i'm not doing that if i'm going to die
then i'm going to die and that's that
but then i went home and i told my kids
and i thought
they look so hurt
and my husband too but it was really
looking at my kids they look
so hurt that it's not my
decision so i'm going to do whatever i
can to stay
to stay alive it's
i realized that's being alive is uh
the focus is about service
it's not it's about what you can do for
others
and that's the christian story
that's an unselfish concern for the
welfare of people who are in you
yes you know that's that's christ's
story
it's his suffering and his
sacrifice you know
it's his sacrifice that we
live by and aspire to
and so i decided that i would
be grateful for every day i had
that i would be grateful for any answers
that came my way
but i would also be
grateful for the life i've had
and so i decided that that was the only
way i could go forward
and be
and be able to accept it